in the meantime
we continue to see
joe biden's approval rating go up
and republicans are furious many of them
are leaving me voicemails which i'm not
going to play because
they're just very lame but republicans
are now saying biden is as unpopular as
ever when of course the truth is joe
biden has seen one of the most
rapid
increases in approval rating
of any president in recent years now
he's still only at about 43 percent
and
it's sort of a glass half full glass
half empty sort of thing you can say
well 43 means 15 57 still disapprove but
you can also look at the last several
presidencies and realize that actually
43
it's no incredible victory but it's
pretty average in terms of where many
presidents tend to be during their
presidency so taking a look at the
numbers now on the screen
you see that joe biden had this sort of
bottom out at 37 and a half percent now
remember 538 is looking at an average of
approval polls
so
it's an it's it's based on more than one
poll these are averages
the approval bottomed out at 37.5
in the second half of july and it's been
a basically direct increase now to about
43 so that's roughly an increase of 15
in joe biden's approval rating and i
have to tell you it sort of makes sense
in that
lots of good things have taken place
many of them associated with joe biden
there's this crew
it's almost quaint sounding
that a president does a bunch of stuff
people like and then their approval
rating goes up because we're so used to
this
highly partisan
almost weaponized approval rating
situation where approval
is
more related to propaganda rather than
accomplishments but we now have two jobs
reports in a row that are better than
expectations under the biden
administration
we have inflation down last month we are
days away from the next inflation number
and my expectation is that it's going to
be down again
significant legislative accomplishments
infrastructure the pact act the
inflation reduction act student loan
forgiveness which is very popular with
americans and it's reflected now in the
approval rating and there's other things
as well
gas prices also are continuing to
experience one of the most sustained and
rapid declines
in a very very long time
and
average gas prices peaked at five
dollars and two cents in mid-june and it
has been declined decline decline
initially very rapid then a little bit
less rapid but continuing down gas
prices are now down to 373 from 5.02 a
gallon that is a
25-ish percent 26 percent decline
that is more than a quarter chopped off
of gas prices everybody's gas bill down
by a quarter
this is a big big deal i don't even
claim it has anything to do with joe
biden i didn't believe biden was
responsible for the gas prices going up
and i don't believe joe biden is
responsible for the gas prices going
down aside from a few cents a gallon
because of he of tapping the strategic
petroleum reserve but i'm consistent
i don't play the gas price games with
presidents
but we know
that that's something many people do
look at when answering the question do
you approve the j of the job that the
president is doing so we'll have new
inflation data next week i expect that
it will be
again a decline in uh in inflation and
joe biden's approval rating reflecting
what is overall
a pretty damn good economy by all
standard metrics and now the question
becomes what does it do
to democratic chances in the fall and
the numbers continue to improve a little
bit at a time a little bit at a time we
will delve into those numbers in more
detail tomorrow the science has shown us
that one of the ways to achieve
consistent deep sleep is to lower your
core body temperature at night it also
is just really uncomfortable to be too
hot when you're trying to sleep our
longtime sponsor chillysleep makes
customizable climate-controlled sleep
solutions that improve your sleep by
keeping you cool at night chili sleeps
cube and uhler sleep systems are hydro
powered mattress toppers they fit on
your existing mattress and they provide
the ideal sleep temperature you can keep
your bed as cool as 55 degrees or as hot
as 1 15 i like 62 personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
is fantastic and chilly sleep is the
only company on the market doing it like
this you'll get 30
off your new cube or uhler sleep system
at chilisleep.com
pacman the link is down below